if you are older than 55 and you have an
underlying health condition
you can now get the covid19 vaccine
however you must get it through a retail
pharmacy
joe mohler is live at the smiths at
decatur in desert in to explain why
joe yeah well the reason people have to
come to pharmacies like dismiss here at
decatur ndi is because there's
medical professionals the pharmacist can
answer medical related questions for
those with underlying health conditions
and with medications
people with disabilities and those who
are homeless are also now eligible
according to the center for disease
control nevada has surpassed one million
vaccines administered
the state is now moving on to those
older than 55 with underlying health
conditions such as cancer
diabetes dementia or kidney disease just
name a few where we have a limited
supply and we do need to reach those who
are at a higher risk
individuals will not have to show
documentation proving a health condition
just like with all the other
prioritization
um truly the only reason is is the
supply issue
state officials will review appointment
availability after this week to consider
opening this to more age groups
we know that people with some of these
underlying conditions like diabetes
hypertension and cardiovascular disease
if they get the virus it can go to a
more severe level
e7 health vaccine expert jonathan
bechtari says talking to your doctor
about the vaccine is important
it's always better to discuss it with
your primary care doctor
just to make sure there aren't any
nuanced stuff for example if you have
cancer and you recently got chemotherapy
now back out here live if you wanted to
see that list of underlying conditions
and a list of locations the pharmacies
around the valley you can head to our
website eightnewsnow.com just click on
this story
reporting live in las vegas joe moeller
great news now our